[Music]
Even though I knew it was foolish, I
kept on searching for this magic.
Ever since I memorized it long ago, I've
chanted it every day without fail.
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
That's the flame of the beginning
That's it  The present is in the final book, the
past, the
future, the forbidden power that transcends all things,
I am the destroyer, the merciless one,
I will not break the commandments of the old gods now with my flesh.
I just kept pursuing it earnestly, and I finally got this magic.I'll never forget this day.
[Music] I'll never
forget its name.
Banana is Megumin. She's the
only genius of the Crimson Demons, and she
can control explosion magic.
[Music]
[
[Applause] [Music]
This is what I wanted to see.
What an explosion, what destructive power, how
comforting
[Music]